Let's head back to Power BI to look at a different query
with the opposite problem that we saw in the earlier demo.
Now we have too many rows.
Here you can see as we scroll down,
there are a bunch of rows that have null values at the bottom,
and we don't want to load them into our data model for many reasons.
One of them is that keys can't have null values,
so that would cause trouble with connecting to things.
But the other is nulls take up space,
and we don't want them adding to the weight of our data model.
What we're going to do is head up to the top,
and we're going to select "Remove Rows".
We can try using Remove Blank Rows, see how that did.
Apparently, only three of the four are showing up as null, so that won't work.
The next thing we can try is removing them from the bottom.
Remove rows and you choose remove bottom rows.
I think there are about 20 rows towards the bottom,
so let's give that a try.
How do we do I missed 1,2,3,4,5,6.
Remember how I said earlier that this is tracking everything we do.
Up here in the top we can see that step.
Remove last number, so remove rows,
so we'll add 26.
Easy enough to fix.
This is a good start.
What we're going to want to do next,
is go ahead and take this first row which at least has
our initial value that we want for a customer rewards members.
I want to use that as my field header.
What I'm going to do,
is go to use first row as headers.
Great. That's a good start.
Now, I'm going to rename each of these columns,
and you'll do this just like you're probably familiar with in Excel.
You just double click,
and we're going to call this customer name.
Double click, customer email,
double click customer phone number.
Now there's one more step that we want to take,
and that's to give our query a useful name.
It imported Table 1 from the Excel document,
but instead, I'm just going to name this customer,
so I can find it easily when I need it.
There you go. Two queries all cleaned up and ready to be useful.
Now, it's your turn to give it a try.